when it comes to car safety Sweden has a
pretty good reputation and it's based in
fact Sweden is one of the world's lowest
rates of traffic fatalities only 2.8
deaths for every hundred thousand people
here's how a Swedish Society became
motorised fatalities quickly began to
rise the number of deaths on the roads
more than doubled between 1950 and 1970
one of the reasons was the majority of
cars were left-hand Drive imports being
driven on the left-hand side of the road
it means the driver is closer to the
curb and further away from the centre of
the road which makes overtaking much
harder because the driver can't see
around the car in front something which
makes head-on collisions much more
likely but on September 3rd 1967 the
Swedish government made a big change in
the name of safety the country changed
to driving on the right-hand side of the
road his traffic infrastructure was
completely revamped in just one day
that included changing 360,000 road
signs understandably safety was a huge
focus the government created a special
team the right lane driving commission
to make sure the changeover went without
incident speed limits in urban areas
were reduced outside of towns they were
introduced where previously they hadn't
existed each day for her ger traffic
Swedish for right traffic even had its
very own song
[Music]
the plenty of other everyday reminders
too like these helpful glasses or HD
underwear the operation was deemed such
a success the government formed the
Swedish Road Safety Agency the very next
year some of the first things that
achieved lowering speed limits and
making seatbelts and motorcycle helmets
law meanwhile the country's biggest car
maker Volvo invented the industry
changing three point safety belt giving
up the patent so that any automated
could use it in their vehicles more than
a million people worldwide thought to
have been saved as a result since the
beginnings of the Swedish Road Safety
Agency fatalities dropped from 1307 in
1970 to 263 in 2015 what makes that even
more astonishing is that in the same
period the number of vehicles on the
roads more than doubled a lot of this is
possible because Sweden is one of the
wealthier countries in the world
it's invested a lot of money in road
infrastructure separating cyclists and
pedestrians from traffic and strictly
police in speed limits and drink-driving
in fact the richer the country the lower
the number of fatalities generally
the ultimate goal is vision zero where
there aren't any deaths on Sweden's
roads at all for many countries there's
still a trade-off between mobility and
the deaths that come as a result of it
in Sweden safety has been the priority
over speed and convenience since H Day
September 3rd 1967
you